- All right.
Let's close this hour with one
last story to make you smile.
This is what I'm liking.
(drums beat)
(crowd cheering)
A far go, North Dakota
man is in a battle of
wills with a mischievous
critter in his neighborhood.
A red squirrel has been
collecting nuts for a
Walnut tree and storing them in the
guy's truck. (crowd
laughing) It's just funny.
(Kelly laughing) (crowd laughing)
Oh my God. Where'd you see the picture?
And this is not just a
handful of walnuts. Look,
it's (crowd laughing) hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds.
It's amazing. You're welcome
for me not saying it's nuts.
(crowd laughing) Because. (crowd clapping)
We take the high road here,
only so many mom jokes allowed
per show. We have this truck
owner on the line right now,
watching on KV, L Y at to
WhatsApp Bill. (crowd cheering)
- Hello Kelly. (crowd cheering)
- You are losing the battle my man.
Is, this has been going
on for years, right?
- It absolutely has. Since
2013, (Kelly laughing)
whenever the Walnut tree produces,
I end up dealing with this issue.
The first time I ever
noticed it was when the
walnuts that were next
to the pickup I got in,
it drove down the street and
I heard walnuts falling off of
it. So I turned around and
came back into the driveway,
opened up the hood, found
a few, a dozen walnuts
(crowd laughing) and had
to clean them up of course.
And this has been a record
year. There's seven buckets.
Each one holds six
gallons of walnuts of this
free little tree dweller decided to store
underneath my pickup this year.
- Oh my God.
- Most ever was before
this was four buckets.
This was a record 42 gallons, worth
six hours to dissemble and
reassemble my pickup to
get them all out of it before I was able
to give away the walnuts.
- Oh my gosh. (Kelly giggling)
It's the craziest story.
(crowd cheering)
So you know that the
squirrel is working hard to
collect those. And then they're just gone.
Like you think that the
squirrel would learn.
Maybe it goes somewhere
else and store them,
but maybe he just laughing
man at you every year.
I don't know. (crowd laughing)
You say, you say that it's a
specific red squirrel in your
neighborhood. Have you named him or her?
(crowd laughing)
- I have not named the squirrel
up leaving that up to the
internet probably, but
other than maybe trouble.
- Yeah. (crowd laughing)
It's going to Dennis, the menace.
Oh my God. It's so great.
Thank you so much, bill.
I'm liking your post right
now. (crowd cheering)
(crowd cheering)
It's so funny.(crowd cheering)
That's not all the man.
I'll see you as one partner
pilot in the goals of pen of
the Kelly Clarkson show
thanks the year squirrely
situation is outrageous
and hilarious like we do.
In recognition, there'll
be using their Frixion
erasable pen to write you a
check for a thousand dollars.
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you very much,
appreciate that. (crowd cheering)
- Oh my gosh. (crowd cheering)
Well thank you so much
bill. (crowd cheering)